Oh
now I I was a great baseball fan and
like many baseball fans I love to play
with numbers and in the offseason of
1979 1980 I was 31 years old and I was
missing baseball and I had this idea for
a game and I there was a game that some
professors of mine at the University of
Michigan and the 60s played that had it
was very it was like you know stone
tablets and a steel chisel compared to
the computer and its level of
sophistication but the idea was
individuals predicting how players would
perform and based on how well they
perform her how well you predicted
whether you the individuals playing the
game win so I I typed up some rules and
came down from Mount Sinai and handed
them to a bunch of baseball loving pals
of mine with whom I had regular lunches
at a restaurant and 52nd street called
lob rotisserie Francaise and said what
do you think in a fume said I think
you're crazy or I think that's boring I
think it's stupid and a few others said
that's great we found some others and in
april of nineteen eighty we had our
first draft now eight of the ten of us
worked in the medium we worked in
magazines newspapers television books
and as a result it got a lot of coverage
because our friends would hear us
talking about it and our friends worked
at newspapers and magazines and
television networks and we got a lot
more attention than had we all been
lawyers and and from that attention
people began to pay more attention and
by within a year or two there were many
people playing a version of it across
the country and we began to publish an
annual book and i would say that by the
end of the 80s it was well-established
people knew what it was big fans did but
it was the internet that really gave it
retro rockets in 1990 the
editor-in-chief editorial director of
the ESPN told me they did a survey of
their their viewers and found the one
and a half percent of them you know knew
about or played fantasy or rotisserie
the original name
sports and so it didn't make sense for
them to do a show about it well now if
you turn on ESPN during the season I
mean the amount of statistics that are
being presented that are only four
people who play fantasy games and
particular shows devoted to an experts
who make a living its enormous and that
came about because the internet made it
so damn easy to follow what your players
were doing and in this film that ESPN
has made about the origins of rotisserie
baseball it shows the control room at
ESPN and I think at Yahoo as well the
computer for the server farm that
handling the the transactions of all the
people who are playing rotisserie sports
you know and it looks like the inside
guts of IBM it's gigantic millions and
millions and millions of people playing
it now
well I think that there's no question
the family sport fantasy sports has
encouraged and nurtured this explosions
mushrooming of statistical material yeah
I feel responsible and to some degree I
once told a reporter Wall Street Journal
did an article about 15 years ago I said
you know I feel like J robert
Oppenheimer having invented the atomic
bomb look what I've unleashed on the
world on the other hand there are all
sorts of good uses of nuclear powers
well and I think that you have to look
at at the obsession with baseball
statistics or sports 260 same way there
there's no question that the statistical
record of a game that exists in a box
score tells you virtually everything
there is no equivalent of that for for
for football and and basketball the
basketball box score approaches it but
you really can't tell much about the
flow of a game the way that you can if
you read not to read it back score
carefully so that the ability to reduce
this dramatic event to several lines of
type I think has really enhanced
appreciation of baseball because I can
imagine the game I can look at a box
score and I can imagine what that game
was like it can take me out of by my
pajamas and my cup of coffee at the
breakfast table into the ballpark and
see things in the stadium of my mind
I think the Philadelphia Phillies are an
incredibly talented team I think the
Yankees are also incredibly talented
team which is to say I have no insight
I've predicted to obvious p teams the
Tampa i think is very very good and they
could they're the one if I were if I
were issuing if I were the handicapper
on it I'd put the yankees and phillies
disco favorites and tap a very close
behind